[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello welcome back to the break room uh
Our Daily Show that keeps you updated on
the nerdy news you need to know we're
excited to be here with you on this
lovely Tuesday today we're talking
stranger things going back to where it
started James Gunn has a plan Tony Stark
giving advice to a specific cast member
of wakanda forever and we talk about
what is Val's plan something we've
speculate a lot on a big lingering
question one of the big lingering
questions coming out of wakanda forever
with me to discuss those things and more
we've got Brandon Barrett oh hello there
we've got Jessica Clements oh hello
um and as always we are not joined by
Tommy bechtold who's on permanent
suspension until we see him in the flesh
he's suspended uh but in lieu of his
presence let's get to some headlines yes
yes oh this is the ginger seat that's
like yeah I understand that's where we
hit them yeah it all makes sense
um so uh stranger things final season
will totally feel like season one this
is according to Ross Duffer of The
Duffer Brothers creators of stranger do
you think he asked his brother brother
before he went out with that statement I
think which one's the younger one I
don't know today I learned ones named
Ross I've never heard anything with the
dropper Brothers well oh my God you you
distracted me so much I was like Ross
and dos and I didn't know why obviously
Ross and doll stuffer were destined it
would be Ross and dose right anyways um
we have met Duffy Duffer the rougher
Duffer brother that's right that's right
he made an appearance in the background
not the one that flips houses uh during
during uh for your consideration panel
uh Ross Stafford was interviewed and he
said uh the final season coming up is a
culmination of all the seasons so it's
start it sort of got a little bit from
each what we're trying to do is go back
to the beginning a little bit
interesting who knows what that means
hopefully means they kill some kids they
didn't kill any kids in the beginning
she was a grown woman I will say we
speculate a lot that cast has ballooned
there's a lot of regulars each season we
kind of add new new cast members and and
none of them die for the most part
a few of them but otherwise everybody
survives so we'll see the fourth season
was especially dark and the first season
was especially fun and it was like 80s
fun second season was a little like
alien sci-fi third season was a full-on
like summer Adventure so if they go like
Goonies amblin tone I feel like that
would capture the whole vibe yeah it
will be interesting because like those
actors are so much older you know it's
one thing when it's like a bunch of 11
year olds on their bicycles 11 year olds
is that how old uh
elevens and year olds
um but now that they're teens right and
they they look like teens and they're
playing teens it is like it changes the
storytelling but anyways we're excited
for that
um hey uh Francisco uh via Pando is
sending in a Super Chat hashtag free
Tommy well
you need to Super Chat a lot more than
that to free time in Francisco uh is
that legal his legal defense fund um let
me tell you he's pretty guilty so he's
gonna need a really empty team a pretty
hefty team I mean we might see Tommy on
the show this week we'll see again we'll
see what the courts decide
um Tony Gilroy showrunner of Andor uh
the break room's official show of winter
2022.
um it's the only show of winter 2022 but
uh he says that uh season two of Andor
will be very different from season one
and a reminder this show Greenlight two
seasons out the gate right like when
they started season one they knew they
were definitely getting a season two
which is the first time that's happened
on Disney plus yeah of all that Marvel
and at least with all the Marvel and
Star Wars shows that we know of
um and they kind of like went right into
production on season two I think we're
getting that beginning of 2024. so it's
a little over a year from now yeah and
it's 12 episodes each season which again
are big package orders yes already the
longest episodes or the most episodes
for a Disney play series and two seasons
which is awesome because we love that
show do you think they're gonna get more
violent oh they're gonna get more sex oh
I I just read something about Disney
plus uh and violence that I'll come back
to you but um uh you said that season
two will be very different from season
one he said uh I'm hoping what we're
gonna do in the second half meaning
season two will make the meal feel
really satisfying I love that phrasing
uh because the first year is really
about him becoming Andor this
revolutionary this uh Rebel uh and we
come back a year later it'll be very
different the next four years are not
about becoming a revolutionary they're
about what happens to people who are the
original gangsters versus the
established yeah I like that we were
just talking in the office too of all
the characters on Andor we only know of
three of them that make it to Rogue one
yes
oh sorry four oh man Forest Whitaker
Diego lunizandor and the dude you just
spoiler alert the duties he's been
hanging out with the last couple
episodes It's a rogue one he just
doesn't he doesn't make it through
Roblox
but even besides those four none of the
other people we've met this season are
in row yeah yeah that we know yeah and
that's an interesting point you bring up
because this first season is like one
year five years away from Rogue one in
the next season they're gonna do more
kind of jumps and cover those four years
in between now and Rogue one yes and get
us like right up to Rogue okay yeah can
I say one thing why would you say Rogue
one thing it no it's an Android one was
like my mom uh was like I'm hearing that
everyone's mad that people aren't
watching Andor should I watch it and I
was like yeah and I explained it to her
and she was like I don't know if I'm
gonna like a character that's already
dead and I was like you should go check
it out and then this morning she was
like are you watching it yeah
Jessica's mom I think she's further than
me she was like he's so fine I think
she's also I think she's also like this
yeah I think she I think she likes the
story and she doesn't like normally like
Star Wars so Andor taking my mom is is a
big deal but she genuinely loves him
he's I'm now going to look into
everything he does I'm doing one a day
so I'm ready for the finale I just
started I'm excited one day and then
when we're done with two seasons it's 24
hours it's exciting we have a whole day
I might start rewatch yesterday free
girl in your super chat you are all my
tribe I would start a rebellion with you
all which Arc has been your favorite
this season of Andor I mean we can't
stop talking about the last episode that
whole prison Arc the prison Arc is it's
just and like what a case studying like
kind of minimalism but I mean it's hard
to pick one it's great also um I'm for
Emperor Palpatine so that's crazy girl
that you would decide to be on my side
well we'll be rebelling against you hey
I'm a follower hi Stark was pretty good
too oh yeah yeah uh speaking of uh
Emperor Palpatine DC's David zazlov are
you guys
[Laughter]
who's currently running uh Warner
Discovery in charge of HBO Max and hey
uh come on the show Zazzle no we love
that
I'm sure like we all have the wrong
interpretation of you he's the guy that
killed that girl that killed scoob a
holiday haunt
um he really crossed
he cried that was a bridge too far
is John Wick a WB franchise is he gonna
get attacked for taking out scoob oh
yeah don't mess with the dog um but
David says he's a businessman he's not a
creative he comes from Discovery uh
where he was famous for like launching a
lot of reality TV and so he comes in and
he's running the DC franchise the Harry
Potter franchise there's a lot of the
stuff and dune don't you dare touch dude
says love
device must flow
look at his face
um I'm dead serious uh but uh
and so like and you know Warner
Discovery they merged you're under a lot
of debt HBO Max doesn't have enough
subscribers they're cutting content it's
it's a little Doom and Gloom over there
but the bright spot
Dune and Gloom uh they did hire James
Gunn and Peter saffron to run DC films
and that is like pretty universally
praised so far we're all really excited
to see what they can do
um and as I've said that they are
writing a Bible for DC films and they're
coming close to finishing that what's a
Bible well so I know in like um
screenwriting particularly for
television they often create Bibles for
shows that are kind of like describes
every character their arcs their
backstory whether that stuff makes Into
The Script or not it's helpful to pitch
the show and for the executives and the
actors and things well and that way you
can bring in writers and be like read
this so you'll understand this is our
continuity yes and like five years in a
real Bible uh
real Bible is a collection of other
stories from around the world mostly
like Sumerians the Phoenicians a little
bit and repurposed into a story that
fits into a narrative established by a
religious conglomerate that controls all
right which also features space Wizards
yeah yeah a singular space
and a um a messiah in the desert like
Dune okay
he is the kids outside around um okay
I think over the next few years you're
going to see a lot of growth and
opportunity around DC oh AKA this is him
talking to shareholders right
to give us money uh there's not going to
be four Batmans that's kind of the quote
we all jumped on there's not even with
that there's a lot of opportunity but
not a lot of Batman yeah which to put
those two thoughts together a lot of
growth and opportunity but fewer now do
you think he meant there's not going to
be four Batmans there's going to be nine
Batman I I just imagine everyone Rose
their hands and he says there's not
going to be four Batmans and then
you pull the camera James Cameron he had
Batman written on the board he comes in
he draws a Batman with an s on the end
that's a dollar sign yeah that Universe
Batman and again the other part of his
quote uh James and Peter referring to
James Gunn and Peter saffron are going
to drive the hell out of DC which is
interesting I mean hey we would love of
it more DC content especially great
content from James Gunn and with his
stamp of approval that would be awesome
it's interesting because like so far
they've canceled DC content they are
doing the they're reversing the hell out
of DC it's not I'm not vouching for that
at all especially if they take doing
away from Zach because I will also write
with Zach but do you think that since
they canceled all these things they're
like okay now our budget for you James
Gunn is to go wild well I I don't know
if it's go wild but I think they had to
show the investors like Hey we're in
this deficit hey this is the bottom line
I don't envy zazlov being the guy that
literally has to put things in The
Chopping Block yeah but now he was I
think very smart too before there's a
fandom before there's a Comic-Con before
there's any real announcements he goes
hey I know you're really mad at me but I
got you the best duo possible right and
now I'm gonna let them make you guys
happy like I think it was really smart
to be the bad guy figurehead because if
this works out in a year if we get to
Comic-Con in July and they go like hey
here's a five-year plan and it's
everything we want like he tweeted Mr
terrific today and like that that's a
great power move to start things off
with and that's also a really good
opportunity because he's still online to
kind of crowdsource what fan opinion is
but leading up to July will have
forgotten our rage and therefore when
this announcement comes out he's gonna
be like see I did this like you get the
negativity out of the way you hire the
two best people for the job you let
things percolate and then you show a
plan that's confident it sounds like
they're making a Bible for a long period
of time I think you come out swinging at
Comic-Con and by then we will have
largely maybe forgiven and and all it
takes is like the equivalent of Kevin
feige on stage at Hull age bringing out
some famous actor to play a character we
love bringing out a director you know
announcing a few new projects give us a
scissor reel give us a trailer and we're
we can forget about all the sins of the
past I was very excited for that girl I
am very excited to one day which is not
possible legally to see that girl but uh
we will find a hole in a fence Warner
Brothers and we can peek through yeah
but you know at the end of the day once
Man of Steel 2 is said out loud there is
going to be a very big shoot as soon as
things like that start coming out of the
date and with characters like you know
Mr terrific who they tease today there
is a great opportunity for the C and
d-listers no disrespect for a character
that a lot of people just don't know yet
James Gunn is very good at making you
love the fact that Guardians the Galaxy
is a household name is preposterous so
not only is he going to be able to wield
the Superman's Wonder Woman's in
Batman's but will it be able to have
maybe your plastic fans maybe your Lobos
all these characters that can fortify
the universe that can cost about 100
million and then zazlov can make a 200
million dollar profit off 100 million
and start making your way back towards
the mega budget films and I think that
you know letting the Batman run wild
with with Reeves and those movies cost
so much less if there's not coveted
protocols being implemented with that
first movie which doubled its budget
then you've got the opportunity to have
a high profit margin using these hard
directors with this great yield to over
the course of five years build back to
as big as Marvel is currently I think I
think it's a long-term great movement
it's a marathon people got to trust in
and I hope I'm right because if I'm
wrong we're just screwed
like there's really no like there's no
it's this or bird and we know we do know
they're committed to theatrical releases
right like that was part of the pivot of
bad girl they would only want to do
movies that are going to go out in
theaters and like we're excited we love
movies and theaters
um just let Aquaman 2 come out Jason
Momoa is waiting I know
those kids are like buying homes those
kids again stranger things problem I was
when I watched a trailer I was like and
I looked them up and I was like okay
this child's getting to start to look
like actual maybe good you guys need to
start switching it up he can play the
Zachary yeah
girl is playing her marriage Marvel is
the older yeah so I'm excited to see
that plot point but at the same time
like Asher and Jack are just like but we
already have a mortgage like they're
like yeah
um we got a couple
um a couple of black panther headlines
and then we're gonna move on to the the
main topic talking about wow
um but in an interview with Indie wire
Angela Bassett forever Our Queen Ramona
um she was talking about when she
learned about her character spoiler
warning
her character dying in the film
um she would she learned that she said
to director Ryan coogler and I will not
do an Angela Bassett uh Ramona at the un
uh no one's asking me
it's Thomas Crown practice can you
imagine her with all the the Pathos and
the acting power that Angela Bassett can
summon her chewing out Ryan coogler she
said Ryan what are you doing why you
will ruin the day you will ruin the
demise of Ramona people are gonna be so
upset and
um uh Ryan cooler it was like Angela I
know I know but look to die is not
really to die in this world it doesn't
have to mean that now do you think that
was him having to remind an adult woman
that her character dying does not mean
that she dies in real life or that was
probably more likely that was like the
insane book your character is not
necessarily Gone Forever imagine being
Ryan coogler telling Angela Bassett that
her character will die and then her
being like what's wrong with you and
even if it's joking I'm like look here I
know Angela I'm so sorry Miss Bassett
but I gotta kill you this is also I mean
Angela Bassett works and gets paid well
but this is probably her bigger
paychecks oh 100 in the last week more
people more people have seen these two
friends yeah then honestly have probably
seen all other combined angels that and
I wonder how much she actually does get
paid for American Horror Story because
I'm sure Ryan she was on after for a
while a couple Seasons so Ryan Murphy
probably makes her to pay Angela Bassett
a hefty fee but the second the second
movie of black panther probably there's
just there's not that many badass roles
for 60-something women in Hollywood
where you get to be a queen and a
fighter and you get to give great
speeches and you're in a movie that
everybody will see what do you think
Viola Davis auditioned for though oh I
would like to say I know she auditioned
audition I would like to see them what
if their roles switched and Viola was
playing uh Ramona and Ambassador was she
playing Amanda Waller yeah the thing is
That's which could easily be done and be
so good and they'd be so different like
I can see her as Waller being so
differently intimidating that's
fascinating I mean her traps she has
better traps than me
neither of them like they don't make
sense
you can't think about it too hard uh
Theodore Harris in the uh sending it in
Super Chat thank you uh one day I would
love a story with bashenga the first
black panther hell yeah speaking of
Viola Davis and her woman King right
like a a warrior kind of film set in the
past in Africa like that'd be pretty bad
did you see it I have not seen it I
haven't seen it yet I want to the reason
it is I don't I'm afraid that I'll get
it very angry I'll get very angry
because you got some days off we know
the story behind in the movie and I'm
like oh wow
um and then final headline here uh
apparently Robert Downey Jr called up
Dominique Thorne uh while filming
wakanda forever and kind of just like as
a fellow uh you know supersuited uh
Marvel character he just gave her some
words of encouragement he said he wanted
the um rigory Williams character to like
be its own thing and not be like
weighted down by the legacy of Iron Man
and he was just like uh she said he was
just super kind and encouraging and said
all the beautiful things that you hope
to hear from the Iron Man himself I
would hope I love that like especially
even characters that did pass away I'm
sorry to force them in this hole or box
I would hope that they do kind of reach
out to their new counterparts in a way
and be like you're gonna be fine
Hollywood can be so Cutthroat but it's
because he got to call his own shot
because he got to go out on his own
terms he does feel like kind of a
paternal thing he's not bitter that they
killed him off or right that he doesn't
get to play that character he choose he
chose to walk away but he still has like
kind of that fatherly ownership over you
know and he wants to make sure the new
people feel well wanted the freedom to
do his own things he did Dr Doolittle
and he's probably like can we on kill
Tony before that was before that was
before that was his existence
where's Sherlock Holmes three times
Sherlock Holmes three I'm excited for
the documentary about his dad do it guy
Richard oh yeah yeah that trailer just
came out yeah September 4th that drops
an Apple TV very excited for that um not
a plug I just made it sound like hell
yeah dude
Apple TV is the best streaming service
available 5.99 a month pay us and and
we'll extrapolate on that Apple TV um
but uh you know who is paying us this
week who ink box thank you to our
friends hitting box for sponsoring all
week on the break room I currently and
now my my the white balance on the
camera will need to be adjusted this is
this is an ink box what
this is an ink box uh tattoo it's a cute
little radish that I picked out now this
guy has been on for over two weeks he's
just starting to fade but he has been
like you don't see dark I don't shower
especially this arm this this one's for
touching this one's for punching ah no I
don't know um but uh he's just starting
to fade but he's looked awesome the
entire time and I'm a person unlike uh
Jessica and Tommy both have tattoos I
don't have any tattoos so it's like you
know when I like walk by the bathroom
mirror and catch a glimpse of this it's
like oh it's like a different version of
myself you know what I mean it's like oh
is this what it feels like to have a
radish
um but they make these like really high
quality temporary tattoos that last a
couple weeks as you can tell by this
one's like this is like day 13 on this
one uh they have thousands of designs
including some cool artistic
collaborations they have some like IP
collabs uh for some of the fandoms
you're you're probably into but what I
want to talk about
and I'm pretty pissed about this okay
okay
currently they also the main thing that
we're excited about here on the break
room is they have this custom maker and
like Jessica was talking about yesterday
about how she's kind of like she has
real tattoos but she tried out an ink
box thinking about she might get it
someday you can if you're thinking about
getting a real tattoo you can design it
in the custom collaborator yeah they'll
send you a temporary version you put it
where you want it you can decide oh this
is the right size or I like this angle
or the the shape or whatever and then
you can adjust what your real tattoo is
like so this is my favorite reason for
it this is the perfect time to get an
ink box ahead of Thanksgiving to really
freak out your family
with that tattoo you should hear about
Mama back and get your mom's name yeah
we got we got some Custom Designs just
for the break room now these don't show
up great on camera because they turn
dark once they're on your skin but
they're really light when they're the
tattoos this one says Mephisto watch
we've got a a new rockstars logo the
custom man R from uh the the YouTube
page and Tommy and I each designed our
own design and then we're running a
contest the early part of this week the
winner will put their design on the
other guy Tommy won yesterday neither of
us were here and yet you the viewers
voted for Tommy well they want Tommy to
get the tattoo no I thought it's the
other way around I don't know but that
means I have to get Tommy's tattoo but
that's what that means okay
we need to find go over with Brandon
because Brandon did say a lot of things
yesterday I said who should get the
tattoo oh and Tommy won yeah so he will
get the tattoo the recipients then I am
sorry for what I said about this well
now they're gonna vote for you I like
you guys I'm sorry so if Tommy wins he
has to wear my It's morbin Time Tattoo
it's got a little clock there and it
says it's morbid time and a fun font
again forever morbid time I'm not trying
to sway people but you should vote for
Zach because this Gucci to moochie it's
huge look at it it's Gucci style Harry
Potter it will have to be like it will
take up an entire half of my chest or
something like that exactly or or I
might do [ __ ] stamps
wait wait I should not be selling this
so hard look at it
can we I want them to see how much of
the
let's run a poll right now we're doing
best of three on these poles yesterday
Tommy won who should get a tattoo Zach
or Tommy okay I wish it went Gucci and
then two moochie like down yeah
what if you get Gucci on your little
lower back oh no I'm currently at 56 I
did too good of a job selling the uh the
[ __ ] Stamp version we want to go to
three days of voting yeah
so if you make this in a tram stand
it'll be too close to the actual Gucci
to check out all the other inkbox
tattoos to do your own custom design or
to check out all their designs click the
link uh that's either on screen right
now or that's in this video description
uh and use code new rockstars uh our
name to get 25 off your entire order so
if you want to get 10 tattoos two a
thousand I was thinking too the old joke
about like you go on spring break and
you get an ugly tattoo well you could do
if you got like a crew of people you go
on vacation with get them all the fake
tattoos I mean you guys can all get
tattoos and not regret it in 10 years
yeah anyways uh use code new rockstars
25 off your order of inbox thank you to
inkbox uh entire order I saw someone ask
I currently don't have any tattoos I
have seven I want well the problem is
I've designed seven that I love and I
know once I start I won't stop so I've
I've not started because it'll be a long
year and I gotta make sure I'm
Deployable so once I have a job that's a
full-time job equals seven tattoos
covered in tattoos that's what they say
sure but the one like the first one I
want is I always say you either die a
Spider-Man or live long enough to see
yourself become a Deadpool so I want to
do like a yin yang of Spider-Man
Deadpool and that way one way is
Spider-Man one way is Deadpool so the
idea would be like if I'm feeling one
way or the other and it's very like
forward right so if I work for like DC
then I mean interesting to invest in
long sleeve shirts how's my name going
on uh well obviously down the tricep
because the show is a fan of my triceps
I always say eating ain't cheating and
so that's why I'm gonna get tattooed on
my body not a secret place you guys
moving on about tattoos the only tattoos
I've Ever Wanted are like the the big
ones I want the full red dragon on my
back so on the dragon these are all
problematic people
I like the big tattoos that take they're
gonna hold back like red dragon yeah
yeah I want the Yakuza like uh yeah so
yeah so I'm the Year of the Dragon my
name's koi and in some mythology if koi
swim upstream become dragonfly
dragonflies represent creative freedom
so theoretically I could get me as a
hieroglyphic my name my ear and my
profession with just a dragon a koi and
a dragonfly but now we're creating a
whole body art situation it's I mean you
speak of the hieroglyphics the Egyptians
had the concept of horror vacuoe they
did not like empty space in their art
that's why it's always full of stuff
they did not like empty spaces
you can't get one tattoo you've got to
come yeah
folks let's talk about our our main
discussion today okay tattoos uh tattoos
speaking of tattoos there was no tattoo
or actual representation of Dr Doom and
black panther wakanda forever that's why
Tommy's been suspended because he
promised uh but yeah we didn't get our
Doom Cameo that a lot of people said it
was going to be there and a lot of
people were like whoa whoa we never said
that uh but he wasn't there but we did
get a surprise uh Cameo from our Our
Lady the beautiful Contessa Valentina
Allegra defontaine uh and she's now been
confirmed as the director of the CIA
which is like a pretty big deal because
that's a very forward uh forward-facing
role in the government before she was
just kind of a shadow shadowy figure but
now she's there uh and one line she said
in the film that really stood out was
that she dreamed about the us being the
only country in the world with vibranium
which is a concept I really liked in
this movie where the you know the first
black panther ended on this promising
note of like well wakanda we're here
we're here to share of our valuable
resources with the world and our
technology blah blah in this movie it's
immediately like yeah you're here but
now we hate you because uh we don't
trust you and you have all this power
and we don't like that you've completely
reset the hierarchy of power in the MCU
uh so she's she's worried right right so
Val works for the government we can
assume what she's doing is cool with
like the other top brass maybe a
congressional committee had to approve
of some of this stuff I don't know and
she wants this vibranting for herself
but what if it's not just for weapons
what if there's something else about
this vibranium she wants it for and it's
kind of magical properties when it
touches soil and plants you know do we
think that Val knows about the
heart-shaped herb uh and its properties
and that it was formed by the the what
kind of meteorite I'm pretty I don't
know what Val knows about the taokins
you know as far as we know their secret
from the rest of the world maybe Val
knows about it and is not playing her
hand there uh but she could know about
their plant as well is that a
possibility here we know the love for
the super soldier serum in the MCU uh is
this like their back door to it like oh
maybe if we like plant some vibranium
and some soil with some some aloe plants
we can get our own little thing going oh
but it's topical right tropical solution
well in the comics especially the
Ultimate Comics which the movies have a
lot of uh you know Venn diagram
commonalities with the Hulk was
basically a super soldier gone right
there's a lot of like oh we kept trying
to recreate cap which turned into this
so I could easily see especially after
the commentary commentary we got with
abomination recently it looks like the
drive to make super soldiers is stronger
than ever between that mention between
us Asian between all these things so I
could easily see them spinning that into
trying to appropriate the heart-shaped
Urban steel and if we've already seen
and laid out very clearly the invasion
of wakanda and we know we got a wakanda
show coming and we've got the
Thunderbolts and they're basically
making a dark Avengers I don't think
we're ever gonna have something called
the dark Avengers because it sounds to
me like Thunderbolts are the dark
Avengers how do you power up new
recruits and I think the heart-shaped
herb is now their GMO does she know
about the heart-shaped nerve though I
think that I thought the only white
person well they didn't talk about it on
the phone sure and so I was like the
only white person that actually knows
about it is one is dead and one is
Everett Ross and I don't think he told
her between I don't know his ex-wife
comes over they have some drinks
we were talking about it is interesting
because like obviously we know of at
least two wakundan Outreach centers the
one we saw in Mali in the in the film
and the one from Oakland and the first
film but like they probably have more
right and they're doing something out
there with their technology and helping
people so it's like on the one hand like
maybe a lot of people know something
about more certainly people know more
about what kind of Technology than they
did before they came out but on the
other hand we were talking about like
there ain't no Outsider tourism in
wakanda they still have a big ass
yes yeah there's no ride there's no
petting zoo in wakanda for like uh
random Italian uh uh visitors or you
know was that new Asgard or I don't know
yeah Canadians I don't know wherever
wherever people are coming from right so
it's still a closed off Society there
they've obviously been picky about what
they choose to share with the world old
right and that's that's why I'm like I
think she knows that vibranium exists in
there especially because the through
history they're the first black panther
where there's literally vibranium Tools
in a museum in Europe it's just like oh
yeah vibranium makes its way out but not
the plant but they didn't know it's
vibrating either right they just thought
it was an old tool they didn't oh no no
no no no no
yeah but I'm just like there is if there
are some weird type of scientist that is
digging up these things and finds it
it's like that stuff that's on her radar
probably yeah I did too that where the
plant grows kind of determines its
powers like the one plant was underwater
so when they ate it they could live
underwater yeah
is land-based so it made you stronger
and faster what if there's one that uh
grew on the walls of a volcano yeah yeah
oh if you could shoot fire powers you
know if you grow in the sky so you can
fly it's pretty interesting this
dovetails MLS bead sent in a Super Chat
why doesn't wakanda give every wakanda
in the heart-shaped herb so now that's a
good question and like it was kind of
even toned in the first one
not everybody necessarily survives that
process maybe not everybody gets the
powers you have to be kind of the the
chosen one to be the Black Panther and
then you get those Powers a rando could
take it yeah and trip balls and never
come back we don't know right like go to
the ancestral plane and not make it back
I don't know I also think uh I clearly
there's this weird kind of Disconnect
where it's like yeah it was in what they
ingested they gave birth so it passed on
to the tolokan children like the babies
but we don't I I mean through t'challa's
son I don't think that it will go
through him to his son also isn't
everyone we've met with the ability at
least somewhat related to chichella
because tataka t'challa his cousin and
they used his DNA to recreate it so
maybe you have to be good yeah it's like
maybe you activate something in a
certain genetic language
this sounds like some stuff that the
tijala royal family is making up to yeah
have the genetics for it this is a
hierarchy of power can't change like I
do think it's dangerous to have everyone
have the power oh yeah could you imagine
if I got a hold of it and I was also in
wakanda or Daniel kaluya right like if
you got it and he was riding those
rhinos and then he fought he's stealing
things all the time from my own people
yeah we were talking a little bit about
beforehand the connection here to the
Thunderbolt right and you brought up
like the dark Avengers like are they
gonna be more like that are they gonna
be more like the traditional
Thunderbolts I mean the lineup they've
kind of presented is not a traditional
Thunderbolts lineup you know this is a
lot of hand-to-hand combat people not a
lot of powers per se capital P Powers
except for like ghosts but most of them
are like accidental powers or like given
powers in a weird super soldier serum
enhanced individuals with Red Guardian
and Bucky but yeah and like someone like
Yelena is just uh uh you know Peak human
right they're not powered up at all in
any ways so is it possible that this
Thunderbolts movie the plot of it could
be something along the lines to like
info infiltrate wakanda or talocon at
this point and steal that vibranium-rich
soil and their vibranium so the
government can create their own Army of
super soldiers and Iron Men you know
this like this next stage because we
know like armor Wars is coming uh New
World Order comes before Thunderbolts is
that is the newer order that like
everyone's got strong guys now we need
lots of strong boys out there uh you
know the power Brokers supplier of super
soldiers team the last person we knew
who could make it is now dead Dr Bell
Ross has always been obsessed with it
it's how the leader got it's all he's
coming back right and the latest coming
back in New World Order so is that the
possibility they're going to go here I
mean they discovered this vibranium in
the ocean they still know where it is
it's not like that's right now it's
still right there I mean they got to get
past the telekinil again watch out for
those drain ass jellyfish watch out for
them jellyfish dog what I think is
interesting is that everyone on the team
is reformed so if you look at the actual
team of thunderbolts in the comic books
there are a bunch of villains pretending
to be
that's your reward it's a lot more like
suicide squad this isn't like suicide
squad this is a bunch of reformed Heroes
that I imagine the leadership is
dastardly so I think it's going to be a
bunch of good guys being convinced to do
a bad thing which lends itself to
wakanda because if you're going to be
doing something that is a positive to
you that you wouldn't know is bad it
would have to be something like uh on a
macro scale so someone claiming wakanda
invaded someone claimed that the lokans
are are a threat then you send your
agency your your thunderboltsies and
then they basically do a Bad Thing even
though they're good people because they
think they're Avengers they also look at
the parallel of these characters like
you've got a Captain America a black
widow a Hulk if Abomination comes in
like we all think he is everyone kind of
parallels the OG so like if you've got a
team of Avengers for the public what
better way to Hoodwink the public than
like hey guys we know how much you love
these Heroes we got their Walmart
versions and like you throw them at you
know whatever and then
guy that killed someone publicly
we've definitely gotten away with way
more no no no no there's gonna be one
family that's like wait a second I know
that guy that was my favorite thing
about the dark Avengers comic book run
was that like they literally wore the
costumes of the regular adventures and
the public had no idea like Norman
Osborne was wearing Iron Man suit and
he's like I'm Iron Man baby because the
public is not watching new rockstars
videos too I don't know it breaks down
um that's actually the wrong suit
little little as a I think I'm
pronouncing your name in ahead of chat
uh what if Andy Circus is character Claw
from the original black panther film
maybe he was telling people about some
of these wakandan secrets right because
he's a guy that got a hold of some uh
vibranium and he was out in the world
selling it to bad parties so like yeah
maybe he also had some knowledge of
getting drunk on his old also one of
these one of these Thunderbolts knows a
lot about wakanda white wolf lived there
the Iowa condom beautiful hair I'm not
trying to be in I'm not trying to be
that person I'm not trying to be that
person I'm not trying to be that person
but I would hate for this entire team to
be like
so we have been invade wakanda and
nothing's wrong I do think like there's
potential not to keep referencing the
most recent suicide squad movie but like
they were sold it's a rescue mission
turned out it was not a they were misled
and it was not a rescue mission they
were there to do something entirely
different so like you could convince Red
Guardian Elena all these people like hey
we know you have a checkered history
here's an opportunity to do great break
into wakanda and steal this you know let
the scientists go that's being held
captive they get in there and they
realize like oh that's not we're not
doing it I just need a really good
justification for Bucky to be like well
we could just alert the door milage that
like because it's like they're better
than he is so it's like I'm bad again
I'm sick of nice yeah
uh well let's get to the real question
here behind this discussion is Val doing
this on her own or is someone is she
working with someone else there's the
idea that she's a scroll yes but to what
end I don't know what and all this yeah
like what would be the school agenda and
maybe we'll find out in secret Invasion
by the time there's trust in the
government if a leader in government is
revealed to be an alien all of a sudden
all bets are awesome having a peacemaker
right clearly was a great yeah and the
irony of you know traditionally the CIA
has worked to destabilize other
countries right look it up eroding
eroding do your own research the
population stressed in their governments
what if she were what if she were doing
that for her own government you know
what I mean she was a double agent
basically working against the greater
good of the American government go ahead
no you go because it's on his line and I
was gonna say by the time we get to
Thunderbolts do you think she's still
the director of the CIA or does
something happen in between now you're
talking about Captain America 4 New
World Order and then Thunderbolts where
she's at a CIA and she's like we got to
do this on our own folks yes and that's
when her her boss Zola shows up and is
like the algorithm says You must form
the Thunderbolts I think
I was disagreeing with you uh so I'm but
I agree with you in the way that I don't
think she's gonna have that position I
think she's ultimate I would love her to
be a scroll I think for storyline that
helps us get more into secret Invasion
but I also really love the idea that
Thunderbolt Ross is still higher than
her I think she works directly for him I
like that makes a lot of sense I think
Mr Harrison Ford plays another get off
my plane president I think I think uh we
have someone at the top talking to uh
Thunderbolt Ross gets elected president
he's in the comics Norman Osborne is so
if you're not using Norman use
Thunderbolt And if you and he goes he
runs as a military leader he runs his
bubble block that gives him more power
you cast
the White House Rose Garden door
explodes
as red Hulk Stomps out
this is my state of the union
um wait never mind kazakhs
this sounds like a wrestling wave
um that's 143 uh a friend from the north
uh welcome from Canada uh saying send in
Super Chat Val is a scroll and wants to
acquire serums and vibranium and other
super stuff to make super Scrolls that's
a nice one ready for some super squad uh
super scroll is a huge part of the
comics we get to see them portrayed on
on film that'd be very cool Fantastic
Four is not far away but we were talking
about David Harbor who is I mean talk
about simu you're still number one for
who we won on this show but Dave David
is not far behind
Barbie you're a number one I'm not
hearing stranger things MCU and Barbie I
mean head explodes but David Harper he's
always given great quotes in the Press
another reason we love that guy but he
said he kind of described the
Thunderbolts he was interviewed and
asked about it and he described them as
losers right like these lovable losers
uh the underdog characters right coming
together but he said you're going to do
a bomb drop in their film
uh and do something that is like a bomb
drop at the end of phase five which
we've been speculating what does that
mean it could be a literal bomb they
just drop a literal bomb but um maybe
it's more of a metaphorically kind of
blow up the MCU as we know it in some
way I don't want to be an [ __ ] but
it's like wouldn't you say drop a bomb
you know like wouldn't you say it a
little bit differently it might be more
like mic drop yeah right that's why no
no yeah no I'm thinking the other way I
think drop a bomb is a mic drop I think
about
yeah John is saying the tone he had in
the interview was more like mic drop
than like uh Hiroshima Nagasaki I mean I
love a good take something out of
context to make it bigger than it is so
I got a theory uh in the comics
Thunderbolts and Civil War and all of
the sokovia Accords happened because of
an explosion there's a character called
Penance who was speedball one of my
favorite c-list characters who's this uh
new Warrior that's really hyperactive I
identify with this young man uh
character that like doesn't really fit
anywhere and he's hyper neurotic and
he's crazy and he bounces all over the
place and then he accidentally causes a
thing that explodes a school and tons of
children die in Stanford Connecticut and
the Stanford incident is what leads into
the sokovia Accords they called it
sokovia because of the events of Ultron
in the comics at Stanford uh but in that
world it's a hero that causes the deaths
of so many if the Thunderbolts are seen
as Heroes and the end of the movie ends
with a hero destroying something it'd be
really interesting if that led into a
new kamala's law if that led into
another round of civil Warf that led
directly into armor Wars that it is all
about out undermining authority and
causing people to want to put their
thumb down in those in power and this
could allow for that if this is I think
there's a lot of room to do some
permanent damage to the Earth leading up
to Secret Wars because secret Awards can
reset everything right it can be like oh
we're gonna move everyone to this new
planet where we can all live in harmony
or they can do a lot of damage to this
planet uh it would be it'd be pretty
insane interesting or or they
it's mostly they lose the entire public
Goodwill but they regain the public
Goodwill by fighting and destroying this
insane extraterrestrial enough Force
I've said it before and I'll say it
again we need to have public Goodwill be
uncertain whether they're with or
against Heroes before X-Men and I think
the best way to have all of this lead up
to X-Men which are not coming soon we're
talking five six years soonest but if
there's this undercurrent of we don't
trust we don't trust and then you've got
Fantastic Four being Marvel's first
family look at these explorers these
Heroes this family this unit and you've
got them as this like Beacon of good and
then the X-Men are not long after and
then it's like the people that don't
trust Heroes now have these mutants and
that'd be really interesting to have the
dichotomy between these Fox characters
that are coming into play at the same
time-ish yeah and and then real quick
because it's also in the thumbnail so we
gotta address it what if Doom is behind
Val right what if she's assembling
um vibranium to serve this master right
because like we've been I it's been my
hobby horses like she doesn't really say
what her agenda is sure she dreams of
the us being the sole owner of vibranium
but we have no other signs that she's
patriotic we have no other signs of like
what is she out for right doesn't wear a
flag on her Lopez that's right hey this
the streak in her hair is neither red
white nor blue
um right strolls were a lot of purple oh
good point uh but like what if they're
I'm just thinking back to like you know
phases one through three where we get
like Loki is the villain the first
Avengers movie but there's somebody
behind Loki it's it's Thanos right like
what if there's somebody behind Val
who's been sprinkled into all these
projects now but like she's working for
a greater Master with a different agenda
that will only be revealed in time and
what if that is Doom right maybe she's a
double agent maybe doom and this in the
MCU will be an apparatus of the US
government somehow right I'm just glad
and I think it's very possible and I
love the idea of I do think Kang and
doom are going to have some
collaboration but I'm very glad just
while we're on the subject of Doom we
heard all those rumors about a
post-credit scene even that like another
actor was in it that was revealed in
another thing I don't remember the
details because I I genuinely would
rather be like oh then see it in like a
shot on the internet and tweet like
through Spider-Man uh but I do think
that there is an opportunity for the
Doom character to be introduced in
another property another property
another property but if it was in
wakanda I think that would have caused
the commercial thing that everyone was
complaining about like a lot of people
said that like the all the raw storyline
with her felt like it was just setting
up Thunderbolts I personally didn't feel
that because it felt geopolitical can
you imagine if we had that post-credit
scene with spoiler alert you're still
here the prince of challenge was credit
scene and then like five minutes later
after we're all crying at her seats it's
like here's the new action
I do think it's really smart to wait
even if it does end up being the reason
for the conflict I'm glad they didn't
try to shoehorn that into this two and a
half hours because it would have been it
would have felt it would have made
everything feel false yeah and we've got
we've got three movies next year and
like six Disney plus series they've got
a lot of opportunities to sneak some
Doom into our lives yeah Doom is going
to show up with a lot of power and when
it comes to climate action your money is
power that's a transition right there
folks with aspiration a new kind of
changes in your pocket and I'm not
talking about Loose Change I'm talking
about changing the world simply by
moving your money to aspiration you're
giving your deposits a cleaner Greener
home aspiration is a climate friendly
alternative for your money get an
account and debit card that's built to
help your wallet and the payment
aspiration lets you plant a tree by
rounding up every swipe of your debit
card chips tree soda tree I buy
everything individually that's not
efficient aspirations been hard at work
helping people align their money with
their values funding the the planting of
over 100 million trees like I said
before it's 50 million hammocks folks on
their way to funding the planting of 1
billion trees by 2030. it's no wonder
why Forbes nerdwall and the penny
hoarder recommend aspiration for the
eco-conscious best of all there's no
credit check no overdraft fees and with
aspiration you just pay what you think
is fair even if that's zero because
money shouldn't stand in the way of you
doing the right thing make your dollars
make a difference
aspiration.com tree t-r-e-e help save
the planet with your aspiration debit
card open your account at aspiration.com
tree today again that's aspiration.com
tree terms and conditions apply
aspiration is not a bank deposits or
FDIC insured up to two million dollars
per depositor two million that's right
you've gotta Jesse things are going well
if you need that insurance
we've also been reminding you for weeks
now weeks to check out the second season
of the hit show DC's Batman the audio
Adventures which is out now uh on HBO
real quick if anybody in the chat has
been watching that show and you have
some favorite moments or some uh some
some thoughts you want to share throw
those in the chat we'll try to read
those yeah yeah yeah uh it's an
incredible cast again this is like an
audio show on a streaming platform I
know it's blowing your minds right now
but you can do it the Catholic Rosario
Dawson John Leguizamo Bobby Moynihan
Chris Parnell Seth Meyers Keenan
Thompson and Jeffrey Wright as the
Batman himself do you think he had to
audition for that I don't know it's an
incredible show
absolutely 100
they sent him the script and he was like
I was almost like anything to me yeah
there it is Westworld callback uh
oh God you can't keep getting away with
it
it's still there doing is still there
it's a credible show it's got crime it's
got humor it's got tons of Batman lore
and it was created by a long time SNL
writer Dennis McNichols that's for you
SNL stands out there tune in for a tale
of life and death in Gotham City is
there any other way the whole season the
whole first season is already available
to stream and season two is out now on
HBO Max stream DC's Batman the audio
Adventures season two now on HBO Max oh
uh Mario 32 in the chat saying here in
Bobby is hilarious Bobby Moynihan plays
the penguin are they saying that they're
hearing that Bobby Moynihan is hilarious
Bobby is hilarious we don't know I think
hearing Bobby's version Lorenzo
Napolitano said I liked when Batman said
it's baton time and batted all over the
Joker I don't know
I hope that's true I just bat it all
over myself can you imagine Jeffrey
writes in it's better than it's Batman
but dead serious with that bass in there
the the vibrato of his voice or whatever
yeah oh yeah
oh are we good teasing for tomorrow
fun
we ran out of time today but Jessica put
a lot of work into it so you got to show
him tomorrow to see it look at that's
the face of someone who put a lot of
work
there's also my rubber dinner
say it's baton timer no no can you do
your Alpha Judo boys
it's that one I was looking for we
should have a Redemption one day that's
you and Tommy going against each other
with uh Impressions
Tommy's really good album looks like
Grumpy Cat yeah I'm saying though
yeah a little bit like is there a
difference has anyone put those two
together no I've never seen him in the
same room at the same place the dumb
dumpy cat oh that's me I'm gonna be Cat
Grumpy Cat apparently but De Niro's
still alive apparently tired of being
grumpy cat allegedly he's like I gotta
kill off grumpy cats uh we think
everybody for joining us uh today uh
other other folks are sending super
chats buggy Barnes ATL thank you always
appreciate you Jeremy Lee uh MLS beads
Quentin it's ever Jeremy Lee I've always
been saying Jay rhyming
uh yeah uh or emerado also also if
you're
able to get your Taylor Swift tickets
it's it's been a tough day for all of us
they moved the Capital One pre-sale time
all you swifties out there I feel bad
for you uh you know my wife's devastated
it's so hard to get the tickets let's
all let's all look out for each other
all right okay and we do it there if you
know a Swifty
say reach out to him if you know a
Swifty say something also if you're in
San Francisco I'm hosting Fan Expo up
there so I'm gonna be sitting on the
cast of clerk Sons of Anarchy like all
sorts of folks
I uh the 25th 26th 27th in San Francisco
yeah
so a week from Friday and like Ming now
when I'm sitting down with uh sitting
down with like like
Titans of Industry will ferdell like I'm
I'm running most of the tables so uh
and and on that same note of uh
promoting Live Events if you're in LA
and you're planning to be at La Comic
Con oh break room we'll be doing a live
show at the LA Comic Con with more
details on that maybe tomorrow or later
this week but um if again if you're
gonna be around we'd love to see you uh
but we thank everybody for showing up
it's official I did win the tattoo poll
today so it's one to one big right off
tomorrow the final decision-making day
tomorrow tune in to see
um we appreciate you all we hope
um you keep it Gucci to moochi please
thanks
[Music]